no I was gonna say some other [ __ ] I
don't want to say it anymore now I'm
thinking about [ __ ] coronavirus
honestly yeah I just popped back in my
head yeah we we [ __ ] it's gonna be
yeah it'll be even by the time this
episode comes out for free mm-hmm it's
gonna be way [ __ ] worse yeah you can
just feel it
can you just [ __ ] feel it the corona
ring yeah vos jeux d'eau very sweating
starts spinning acid can Corona Mars
kill you there are deaths from your idea
I don't know it's like compromised
immune system is that we have probably
if you have like if you're yeah weak
yeah few so like a beta male yeah yeah
if you're like if you eat soy yeah
definitely diet from coronavirus exactly
yeah um so yeah it just feels like all
these tweets that I'm reading it's like
it's that feels different from like the
swine flu or not ours yeah he that [ __ ]
it feels like I just feel like that [ __ ]
was contained early yeah this really
feels like something totally different
you know I know like just from the
hysteria from media just like the the
vibe you know
yeah every day there's the vibe check is
like not passed from passing yeah
coronaviruses failing of objects
seriously severely failing it did like I
didn't like I thought I was bad in
school and like this vibe is like super
off yeah yeah yeah nah i am thane SSE's
me out is we
they sketch me on us yeah stresses me
out is like kissing another dude nah I'm
gonna sketch me out as we land here and
look on Twitter and they said Australia
will now act as though kovat 19 is a
pandemic but that's a good thing though
for us it is but it also feels like some
[ __ ] government [ __ ] where it's like
they know it's a pandemic and they go no
we're just gonna tell them we're acting
like it is yeah but it [ __ ] you don't
know me yeah yeah there is some
Chernobyl [ __ ] but it's also like we
got off the plane we've read that and
that's all I'm walking towards customers
being like I wonder what if anything's
gonna be different like are there dudes
in hazmat suits they're like spraying
people down and [ __ ] like that cuz it's
like it's a if it's a pandemic like a
you know that's what it was in China you
see these [ __ ] videos that people
walking on the street just sanitizing
buildings with these giant hoses of [ __ ]
now you know what happened dude
we got here and this is gonna act like a
pandemic and so everyone has to go to
the screening room with Hobbes and Shaw
you stand there and the rock gets your
[ __ ] results and he looks at he looks
as day than when he goes she has the
virus we have to go to a fortified
building to get her taken care of or she
ends shoots him right there and that's
how they're treating the coronavirus
going forward gotcha yeah okay yeah
that's cool you just go through the
Hobbes and Shaw tank yeah that room yeah
yeah they do and they do that they do
that scene for every single person so
customs tails [ __ ] forever yeah it
takes forever then they [ __ ] like
Hobbes's mom is sometimes there with a
flip-flop and you have mobs outta line
yeah so the mom has to be there to be
late
Family Values yeah remember where you
came from yeah I love that part of the
movie Family Values that's so funny
that's the part of their resonated with
me like oh yeah
you're whooping your ass yeah that's it
family is like a foot 400-pound dudes
with covered in tattoos and man-bun
plural are all standing around this like
sure that mom sitting in a chair with a
flip-flop and they're only I'm sorry mom
yeah yeah
she'll beat that ass yeah family that I
got a respect you just making them
smarter
yeah so yeah coronavirus yeah now so we
go in there and customs was no different
nothing no [ __ ] screens have you been to
China and to when who wants no I haven't
no okay go on how easy would it be to be
like no yeah just like spit on your visa
just rub it out with your thumb look at
the [ __ ] passport
you don't look at hey the stamps nothing
just [ __ ] there just trusting you
yeah no of course I didn't go not in
[ __ ] not in Amsterdam they went
through everyone's [ __ ] Passport
did they really oh yeah they were like
page by page it was like the most Dutch
[ __ ] ever like ladies liked what you're
looking at the stamps or just trying to
find an empty spot to stamp no no
looking at really visas huh have you
been to China in the last 14 days you
got a little yellow stick I see you went
to Cambodia in 2004 so it's [ __ ] is
Chris said some dude was like I was
there but for like New Year's and the
lady was like I guess that was four
weeks ago you like make a call there
like I guess we legally we have to let
you on Chris said everyone in line when
I saw he's got a bomb he's definitely
got a bomb in it I saw him pack a bomb
in there ya know took it out he dusted
it I for sure saw the bomb yeah you know
had a bomb joke earlier but I don't
remember joke well we're on the plane
before the plane anyway so the Australia
article read that one as soon as we got
off the plane and then like there's
another one that says like the first
confirmed case of someone who wasn't
directly linked to China or anyone that
came from China
mm-hmm just happened or just was
confirmed in the States in in Berkeley
or UC Davis or some like that you know
so basically she had symptoms seven days
ago and went in to get tested and they
the CDC denied a test because they were
basically she doesn't like qualify for
it because she doesn't have any links of
China and these are just flu symptoms so
they denied it and so turns out seven
days later she tested positive for it
and she's just been around UC Davis now
for seven days she's interacting with
people for a full [ __ ] week so this
has to be like the start of something
huge in the States at least yeah yeah
that's um that's really [ __ ] not cool
it's really not cool and someone else I
read a tweet like a reply that was like
someone living in that same area it's
not the bay area that's like North yeah
and they were like I just went to the
grocery store and like everything sold
out you've learned like buying food for
emergency supply and just hoarding it a
[ __ ] dude it's weird man I don't know I
don't know how like sensationalize all
this stuff is but like it feels like
something
yeah the funniest [ __ ] was when we went
to the UK and I wore and I wore that
facemask and I just took a picture of it
just to be whatever on Instagram some do
goes bro don't wear a face mask there'll
be a sheep dude don't believe the media
you [ __ ] simp yeah you [ __ ] simp
ass [ __ ] stupid ass dude I'm like
[ __ ] you go to the virus yeah
yeah I'm getting on a plane I'm going to
a place where I don't know I mean it's
not really it wasn't in the UK but it
could be anywhere you don't know it's
just scary cuz I forgot I did we land in
Heathrow we didn't landing you know he
throws a [ __ ] huge Airport
yeah did so many people go through you
throw yeah
that's what freaked me the [ __ ] out I'm
just like a like I said a few episodes
ago I mainly did him does remind myself
don't touch your [ __ ] highs don't
touch her don't just don't cuz you have
a habit of going to the bathroom then
licking my hand after work yeah yeah I
can't stop yeah like I want to grab and
flush the toilet with my hand and then
just lick my palm yeah yeah and flush it
yeah a lot of tying a long rub the
handle yeah I get as many germs yeah I
wipe the seat with my hand yeah to clean
it nah cuz I'm a sicko but then I'll
look at afterwards after this for the
next person is courtesy to just wipe
that off there's a germaphobe listen
right now that just go no it's it's
funny cuz like when we get on the plane
normally Kelsie will take out you know
like antibacterial yeah
sheets and like clean the seats and I'm
always like what the [ __ ] you doing I
saw you guys doing that [ __ ] good a to
the eye does but now I'm like yeah
five of those [ __ ] so normally I
don't is the only time I only did it
today because someone spilled a drink on
my seat aleem is the one that does it we
got on the first plane it's like she
looked at me she's like wipe your seat
down I'm like my wiping this [ __ ] and
I'm just sitting there just again
licking the outlets licking the hand
yeah yeah arm rest as you do yeah just
getting a feel for things yeah and
that's really how I you know you know
I'm able to feel comfortable
it's like scent and taste yeah I
actually go to the headrest where people
lay their heads and I try to touch just
a little part of my eye on it oh do you
yeah just oh it's like a little why's
that just to make sure like the moisture
is appropriate for my head okay yeah
it's too dry you know and you'll know
because you're not like I always stick
to it your eyes a good judge of moisture
yeah it is I mean yeah yeah make sense
cuz if my eye sticks to it then it's not
it's too dry yeah but if my eye just
coming to clean
on the seat there's a nice little kids
yeah oh yeah sometimes I'll take you
know the the headphones that they give
you and I really just worried my mom is
in there just to get like a little bit
just at least a little bit of ear wax
you're the last person yeah this is
judge whether or not they I actually
asked for the last person's blanket and
pillow Oh actually the last is what yeah
yeah cuz I really want to feel good
smell them yeah one for severe yeah yeah
certainly feel like I'm part of their
pack yeah
you